[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
december is upon us the final month of
2021 and there's a handful of games
vying for your attention like usual i
found a few free games too to save you a
few dollars pounds euros rupees over the
festive period so for the last time in
2021 here's what games are releasing
this month
who doesn't want to play a survival
horror game just before christmas take a
look at five nights at freddy's security
breach this series has a cult following
and there's now 13 installments overall
with the events insecurity breach taking
place after those in help want it we
play as gregory who is locked in a
shopping center filled with murderous
animatronic mascots our job is to stay
alive as long as possible as we are
hunted down usually in the dark the mall
reopens at 6 00 am so can you survive
that long from the gameplay released we
can see that this is the first five
nights at freddy's game with full free
roaming we are totally in charge of our
actions and where we go next security
breach uses each store and area in the
mall to scare us in different ways is
there anything scarier than crawling
through a kid's soft play area all alone
only with torch like for company
there's gonna be so many jump scares in
this game i'll be honest horror games
really unnerve me but should this video
receive 15 000 likes i will play and
upload a video about five nights at
freddy's security breach december 16th
is release day on ps4 ps5 and pc what do
you think to the new direction of five
nights at freddy's
[Music]
remember when among us took over the
world let's be honest
are you still playing it regularly now
well many of us have actually been
waiting to play on console since its
release and finally on december 14th
playstation and xbox owners can join all
the lies and stab their friends in the
back if you haven't played much among us
recently you may not know about the
multiple updates to the game from
increased lobbies and colors to brand
new roles as engineers a player can vent
like the imposters camp as a scientist
you can keep a constant eye on
everyone's heart rate to see who dies
and there's a shape-shifter too who can
morph into other players among us has
definitely evolved wait there's a
guardian angel who can protect other
players and there's an in-game star too
december 14th is the day the playstation
xbox fan joined the party
take a looksie at white shadows a 2.5 d
puzzle platformer in the vein of great
games like limbo and inside incredibly
atmospheric in an unsettling way it's
essentially a commentary on modern life
told through raven girl and her attempt
to escape a plague ridden city in a
world where only the wealthy can afford
to live escape is everything my fellow
limbo fans you should know that white
shadows drops on playstation xbox and pc
on december the 7th
december is full of platformers another
one releasing this month is solar ash
but the key difference here is speed
solar ash is all about flow chaining
together skills to seamlessly explore
the world skating across the ground or
jumping effortlessly stabbing those in
your way timing becomes a key mechanic
especially in boss fights and the art
style is something you'll either love or
hate solo ash hits playstation and pc on
december 2nd at this point i really
wanted to talk about tmnt shredders
revenge but that game has now been
postponed to 2022 rip not cowabunga
that's pretty much it for the full price
games this month so let's do free stuff
i don't think we can call this first
game a game it's more of an experience
if you're on playstation or pc right now
you can try out kid amnesia back in 2000
2001 radiohead made back to back
critically acclaimed albums called kid a
and amnesia you see how the title works
now this exhibition brings together
recordings from the band and visuals
from someone's dark mind together in an
experimental presentation it's weird
it's really weird it's also out now
another free game which is the opposite
of that is exposed reloaded a very
simple game in which you draw lines to
capture bots on screen in mini prisons
the level ends when the playing area is
sufficiently reduced i'm not completely
sure this is supposed to be free right
now but it is so if you want to try this
game do it quickly and it does support
trophies too my search for free games or
any games this month took me to some
strange places like this gardenia
prologue another free-to-play game
available right now with an expansion
coming in december on playstation xbox
pc and switch this one is more like a
zen game in which you build the perfect
garden your job is to make this island
inhabitable again and bring back the
locals it's kind of like a mix of
minecraft and the sims it's not for
everyone but maybe it's for you and i
know this is a playstation focused
channel but if you're on xbox you should
be playing halo infinite the multiplayer
portion is free to play so go play it
and we can't have a free game section
without talking about blood hunt on
playstation remember all those months
ago i was telling you the devs promised
to release this game in 2021. yeah well
they moved that update to january 2022
so i guess i'll be talking about this
game again next month see you then yay
[Music]
final fantasy 14 exploded in popularity
thanks to a realm reborn a new beginning
to the massively multiplayer
role-playing game which has since kept
players coming back constantly it
finally made its way over to console
this year and the eagerly awaited
expansion end walker is now finally
ready to drop on december 7th we will
face the galayan empire that threatens
our homeworld i'm very new to this game
but i tried out the beta for the
expansion and wow i really can see why
this is a big deal the game has a
free-to-play element too a trial which
lets you level up 60 times before
meeting a paywall
enough time to see if final fantasy 14
is your jam and if you want to spend
hundreds of hours living in this world
so there we have it december isn't the
greatest month for new video games this
time around but holy heck wait until you
see the games releasing from february
2022 next year is going to blow your
socks off i'm adam you're awesome i
challenge you this month to reveal
something weird about yourself in the
comments i'll go first something weird
about me i bite my own toenails i
probably shouldn't have said that anyway
thanks for staying till the end see ya
[Music]